coming to the metro stop marbig is an
emotional experience for long do all it
was here that a bomb exploded on Tuesday
possibly killing his best friend like
many of the missing he's not yet been
officially identified as one of the dead
as long as we don't have an official
death certificate for us he's still
alive we will keep fighting to believe
in that and continue to send him
positive energy for us it's a question
of survival the fight for survival
continues for several victims at leuven
University Hospital the clinic was one
of the major arrival points for the
wounded on Tuesday but identifying them
has been difficult it's a horrible act
because everybody knows it can be your
family it can be your friends who are
there and these are terrifying wounds
which we never see before it's not like
a car accident where you happens this is
really everywhere metal everywhere the
skid novels so in the horrible wounds
lawhon duo is still hoping for a miracle
and that he can come back with his best
friend to their favorite restaurant
where for the last 20 years they used to
have dinner together but he knows the
chances are slim if people tell me in
the next few hours that he's dead I'll
have to live with that I live in the
moment I have so many good memories of
all the things that we went through
together no one can take that away from
me usually considered directly but it
could take several weeks until lon do
all knows for sure like him many other
friends and relatives are still hoping
that their loved ones are among the
survivors